how did the script for don't blink find
you or did you find it
i would say i found it um i worked
at raising money for financing for a
bunch of years
and i really knew i had no idea what i
was doing and eventually
i was introduced through my producing
partner carl carl lucas
introduced me to gentleman nathan uh
lobieski last name very difficult to say
and they agreed to give me money and
they said zach you can write it direct
it produce it star in it
i said no i don't want to do that
because it was the first thing i was
doing
as as a producer and uh i didn't know
how to do everything at one time
i said to them look i'd like to produce
or direct
and on this one i want to produce um
and i have somebody i think would be a
good director for it and then
also my scripts at this budget level are
more comedy
and i don't think they travel as well
because uh
people laugh in different countries and
the cultural value of
comedy doesn't really transition well in
other languages so
comedies do okay in the country but not
necessarily outside
but everybody goes boo the same way
and then starring in it i'm like i would
like to get bigger names than me in
order to help guarantee distribution
and so those were my thoughts then a
friend of mine travis oates
who was i was working at acme comedy
theater i was part of the acme a team
so every saturday night you do basically
like saturday night live type of thing
uh sketch comedy and he was
the owner of acme at the time and he was
a scriptwriter who had sold a bunch of
different scripts to large studios and
so
he had a stable of really good scripts
and he had this concept for one
uh and so when i told him the budget
level and he
wrote the script in like three days yeah
he's that guy he's
like gets it done super fast
and so he did it and he directed it so
yeah i brought him on board and then i
brought brian austin green on board and
um brian was the contact to me to savari
because they worked together on the
movie domino
and brian and i had worked together on
uh
terminator the seraconic chronicles and
which is a funny story because uh
i play a hero from the future and so if
you're coming
from the future to the present in the
terminator world you're naked
um so that's a great way to meet the
entire
cast and crew
i'm a white guy i'm a ginger so this is
you know needs a tan
you know what i'm saying and um so the
first thing is like i
in my macho pose future ball of
cosmic energy and my chest explodes
because i've been shot
in the future and then it as i pow
kirk and i go away and i'm walking
around everybody like
hi this is uh nice to meet you
kind of embarrassing to be honest and
i'm sitting down and brian austin green
walks over and he's a big dude like i
don't know if you know that but like
he's like
six two-ish and he's like he looks like
he plays football he's a big cat
and uh i'm sitting down on set in my
bathroom feeling
uncomfortable and he's eyeballing me
he's like
how do i know you okay i don't i don't
know you saw me naked over there and it
might
be he's like no where where are you from
where
apocalypse almost famous like no no no
christmas stories like oh my god i love
christmas story my son loves christmas
story watch it every year and he
pulls a fanboy it was hilarious i'm like
okay creepy i'm not wearing any clothes
so we start butting it up and then i
reached out to brian
and i told him about the script he read
it he loved it
um he came on board which was huge
and brian is very talented like watching
him and
like well you know i didn't know his
work really before since 90210 i hadn't
really paid attention to him and i
didn't really care for 90210 because i
wasn't a little girl a teenage girl
so when i saw him on terminator i was
blown away by how good he was
like holy crap he's just really
profoundly full and uh so when he came
on board with us
i was very happy and then he brought
amina
and that's how we got everything kind of
running
i think i answered the question you did
what was the time frame from when travis
right he wrote the script
three days then when did you actually go
to the location and start shooting
we did we got the script we got the
money in like
august of 2000 yeah again in like august
and then we got everything set up
written
locked down location scouting casting
october and then started shooting
january
january 2nd second wow
so yeah no it's still still with
champagne residue in your hair or
whatever yeah it was awesome
and i i went we were shooting in rio
dosa new mexico
but carl uh is from roswell new mexico
and there's a film class film
you know the film department right now
sorry tired uh film department in there
and there's also like military barracks
nearby so i'm staying like military
barracks on a cot
you know and uh my my girlfriend at the
time was like well
what didn't you do something for
christmas i'm like
sweetie i i've got a movie
santa claus came this is all good i
don't need anything else this is all i
want to do i want to go through
contracts
i want to learn the dga this is awesome
that's all i wanted there was nothing
else that anybody could give me
besides that that was just ecstatic so
uh yeah we shot for
22 days yeah six day weeks
which is always everybody who's a
filmmaker out there will know six day
weeks
suck and the first day back after the
one day weekend nobody's friendly
nobody's friendly